[Music]
to be born here is a gift
wild one
here we are free
[Music]
i never wondered what lay beyond the
stars
[Music]
everything i needed
was here
when the ship crashed
i was curious
as you are
[Music]
and it nearly killed me
that ship is what you saw
i searched it and found nothing
nobody
an empty cargo ship driven by computers
a cargo ship with no cargo never mind
the outside world
our world is dangerous enough for you my
wild one
what does gds stand for
what's the only truth
everything wants to kill me
and what's the only rule survive
survive mara
survive
[Music]
never mind the outside world
i searched it and found nothing
nobody
an empty cargo ship
driven by computers
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no my mom was born here she told me so
prisoner
0323 return to yourself
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're going to die my wild one
i told you
i i told you not
i can't save you
not on my own
[Music]
distress signal received authorities are
inbound
what's the only rule
[Music]
survive
you